all right the raiders are counting down
the days before saturday's pre-season
opener against the seattle seahawks
sports director chris matthews joins us
live in studio with more on today's
press conference and chris i know
there's a few of those players who are
who can't wait to kick off the season
right not only the players but all of us
here at channel 8 also unlike last
year's been a full season now this year
they had the camps and other off-season
activities to kind of prepare for the
season they brought in a whole bunch of
new players many of those on defense now
with one of the worst defenses in the
league last year boy it's going to be
interesting to see what happens this
year so this year the raiders focused on
improving that defense they brought in a
number of guys including pro bowler
former pro bowler gerald mccoy now he is
the real deal if father time doesn't
chase him down he was away from the game
for a year mccoy knows what it's like to
be a professional in the national
football league and he's helping others
learn that as well
this i believe
that this team is going to catch a lot
of people off guard and there's a lot of
town in this locker room
and um
defensively
you know
what i can bring is just my leadership
and experience more to just
what i can do on the grass what i can do
um you know on the side while guys are
learning in the meeting rooms
outside of the building
just teaching guys how to be pros i
always believe there's a difference in
being a professional and a pro once you
sign a contract in the nfl you're a
professional doesn't make you a pro
being a pro is how you approach every
day
how you prepare how you watch film what
do you do when times get tough on the
field what are you eating
oh yeah a lot goes into being a pro in
the nfl also today some military members
visited legion stadium to have a little
fun with some coaches to check out the
raiders new two billion dollar mansion
they enjoyed some time on the field ran
a few drills enjoyed lunch along the way
coming up at five we'll have more on the
fun community event involving some of
those from the military you'll hear how
hard it was to get through some of those
drills now you can't be a ventriloquist
with this you gotta you can't be both
guys you gotta be one guy there's no
faking it here on the field uh christian